live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsey show where
debt is dumb cash is king and the paid
off home mortgage has taken the place of
the bmw as the status symbol of choice
we help people build wealth do work that
they love
and create actual amazing relationships
open phones here as we talk to you about
your life and your money ken coleman
number one best-selling author ramsey
personality host of the ken coleman show
is my co-host today as we answer your
questions the phone number is triple
eight eight two five five two two five
triple a eight two five five two two
five robin's in charlotte north carolina
starting off this hour hey robin what's
up
hi dave hi ken thank you for having me
sure what's up
i am currently 51 years old
and i live in my primary home which i
owe 205 000 on
i have a rental property that i owe 115
000 on
i was thinking about selling my primary
residence
and with the proceeds paying off and
moving into the rental which i could pay
off that house and have no mortgage
i would leave my current job
where i make about 90 000 and find a new
job which i may enjoy
more and once
and not need to make 90 000
does this make any sense
i think it makes total sense i mean we
got to walk through the financials on
this assuming that uh you can sell the
house at what you believe that uh you
can get for it and and you can move
through this because if if you're sound
financially
then
then moving back in pay
to do work that you love
then i'm fine with that but but moving
back and assuming that you have to move
back and pay just to do something you
enjoy at the
at the risk of putting yourself in bad
financial shape or putting yourself in
you know a tight situation is never a
good move so if you've got the margin uh
and you can do it sounds good to me so
let's play this out you give us all the
other numbers
i want to ask what would be wrong with
making a hundred and twenty thousand
dollars a year doing something you loved
why do you always have to move back and
pay to do something you like well that's
not assumption well it depends on the
job so what's that job that you would
look at that would be less money that
you love do you know
dealing maybe more with
animals
okay work how working with animals and
how much sounds like you haven't done a
whole lot of research on this
because the goal is to pay off the house
right it's the peace of mind i get that
but here's the deal the way you set that
up
is assuming that you can get a job that
you really really enjoy and still pays
you plenty whatever plenty needs to be
and i don't think you have a specific
idea in mind which means you don't have
a plan
and you really don't know what that
could look like so i'd have to say no
this doesn't make any sense until we
have a clear destination of what we'd
want to pivot into professionally
because there are times dave there are
times if you move completely different
of line of work
where you know you don't have the
earning potential that you would in
another place but that's not what's
going on here
there's no work destination
it's just an idea i want to work with
animals and have less stress because
people suck yeah i'll go with that
but you got to know how you're going to
work with animals you got to know where
you would work with them what it what it
takes to get qualified how much that
cost how long that takes there's a lot
there that you need to have clarity on
before this makes any kind of sense
professionally
yeah so
i i'm going to go with ken on that part
of it the
um
yes robin if you want to sell your house
and pay off the rental moving the rental
live debt free that's not a bad idea at
all that's an awesome idea uh what i
don't like is the assumption
that in order to do something you love
you have to make less i do something i
love i paid off my house and i made more
every year
since then every single year for 30
years my income's gone up every single
year
and i made more in my life than i ever
dreamed i would ever make in my life
sure and i'm not saying you have to go
do that much but um
but you know
you can work with animals and i uh i
don't know maybe you become a
veterinarian and make two hundred
thousand dollars a year um that's
working with animals so if i was in the
bucket yeah it's very expensive
i got it i got it i got it i'm just
saying this idea that that we have to
make less to do something we love well i
agree that runs around all over the
culture and it just irks me yeah sure i
get that you you ought to make more when
you're doing something you love because
you ought to be better at it more
enthusiastic uh more productive uh
learning becomes fun because you're
learning about stuff you want to fool
with
well i just want to give and i agree
with you dave you're right about this
sentiment however just for the broader
audience here i there are i've talked to
people on our show uh here and then and
then and then on the ken coleman show
where people said hey i want to
transition from i was in a corporate job
and i want to be a teacher you know that
happened so there are times where you
know you're capped as a teacher there
are certain professions where you can't
every year just keep going going going
you may get some incremental increases
that's the only caveat that's what i'm
talking about if you're really if you
feel like that's what you really want to
do and financially you're able to absorb
that then that is a case where you'll go
do something work you love and you'll
make enough money so robin uh hang on
we'll send you a copy of ken's book and
it'll help you with the clarity part of
the process uh from paycheck to purpose
read through that but you need to get a
clearly defined
career path
and start asking yourself the question
what have i got to do to do that
um because otherwise you may end up
making fifteen thousand dollars
um you know working part-time in the
back of a veterinarian clinic uh
shoveling animal stuff i mean i don't
know i mean that's what could happen if
you don't have a plan here you could
really you could really take a dive i
mean it could be bad so you really need
to have this exactly what i want to do
oh and by the way that pays 65 000 and
not 90 and then that makes my move into
the debt free rental a lot of sense okay
i'll shut up and go with you then but
you need to have this very very much
clarified neil is in raleigh north
carolina hey neil what's up
hey dave how you doing great man how can
we help
um well i uh my wife and i are in baby
steps four and six and uh in in part to
your guidance we really appreciate that
cool my question for you today is uh
about a career path change
um so i i like the company that i work
for been there almost a decade i make a
about um 75 a year with quarterly
bonuses and that amounts to
close to about 100 000 a year um my
problem is that there's no real career
advancement um i've been available for a
promotion for some years now being told
that i could move up and
uh it hasn't happened um and it seemed
to be a bit of a stalemate i certainly
want more of a challenge um i received a
job offer um for another um another
company um but it's in only
and um it's not necessarily cut out it's
what only
it's commission only okay
um
and uh their advancement plan it's it's
a current sale
a field that i'm
totally familiar with and
necessarily comfortable with
but i do know that uh that it would be a
new challenge
and the income potential would be much
higher okay cool i'll tell you what we
come back from this break we'll come
back and talk about it we'll also see if
we can get your phone dialed in because
whatever it is is skipping all over the
place hope you're not selling that cell
phone
uh so
we'll be back we'll be back in a minute
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
if you're looking for ways to update
your home without blowing the budget
i've got it for years i've been telling
you about our friends at blinds.com
blinds.com makes it simple to shop top
quality blinds shades and interior
shutters from home with easy online
ordering and free shipping with
blinds.com there's no need to renovate
your entire home just change out what's
on your windows with upscale choices
like faux wood blinds cellular and
roller shades or even outdoor shades
plus blinds.com guarantees the perfect
fit whether you do it yourself or you
have them measure and install everything
for you shop their latest looks and see
how much you can save at blinds.com
today the easy and affordable way to
make your home more beautiful is
blinds.com
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
well our live events are in full swing
tickets are selling really fast for our
smart conference our all-day event
experience that's in dallas texas on
saturday october 22nd
if you want to hear from world-class
thought leaders who will refuel and
empower you in every area of your life
money career anxiety relationships
marriage leadership
join us at the smart conference the
speaker lineup number one best-selling
author of know yourself know your money
and two other number ones rachel cruz
number one best-selling author of own
your past change your future mental
health and wellness expert
dr john deloney best-selling author and
number one best-selling author of the
book paycheck to purpose america's
career career coach sitting to my right
ken coleman best-selling author and
founder of life church craig groeschel
his wife amy they'll be talking about
marriage
the newest and hottest ramsey
personality that everybody's buzzing
about a fine print podcast host george
campbell will be speaking and some
surprises as well oh and i'll speak all
day long baby
all day long and you're going to leave
there tired and informed and smarter
that's why we call it the smart
conference it's only 39 to come to this
thing and um
you know it's an all-day deal it our vip
platinum event passes are sold out but
uh we've got general admission passes
available for 39.ramseysolutions.com
events now before the break we were
talking to neil and raleigh and neil it
sounded like you had a a good job
currently making it was like 150 plus
bonuses was it
uh about a hundred thousand about a
hundred thousand plus bonuses but there
were no uh uh no promotions coming and
so you're thinking about jumping to this
other place but the problem was it was
straight commission and i think that's
about how far we got before the break is
that right
yes sir okay so what do you think you'll
make if you took a straight commission
job
um i think i would probably start a
little bit slow be a step back um based
on my calculations probably about 75 and
then
um
up from there uh i think i'm
pretty good at selling um certainly not
selling the cell phone as you mentioned
i i
i think i could probably make a good
living i
don't know if that's something that i'll
be passionate about and would end up
looking for another career
does it does it give you the ability to
get promoted there
um it it kind of has its upper ability
but i'm not quite sure about
the structure of it all yet have you
gone through the interview process or
are you still in the middle of it
i've been given the uh the job offer but
um i've actually i've got a few more
comments coming up with some additional
questions before okay you gotta dive in
you gotta dive in there and you gotta
ask questions like hey listen uh you
know what is the what is the company's
policies or what is the behavior like as
it relates to developing people and if
you crush it opportunities to get
promoted you say it that way you don't
ask for demands just hey what's what's
what's the process like how does a
person get promoted in this company
that's a really good and thoughtful
question and it gives you a chance to
kind of look at them in the eye and also
process their answer i would dive into
that the the concern i also have dave is
uh neil you mentioned you know i don't
know that i would love the work and you
don't have to always love the work if
we're climbing the ladder okay you do
what you have to do so you can do what
you want to do that's just the reality
but i would dive in a little bit more
you can get a hold of some people who
are probably doing that kind of sales
work
maybe you can talk to some people who
are currently employed there i would dig
in a little bit and go what's an average
day look like what's an average week
look like and i think you're smart
enough to know yourself and be aware is
this something that i'm going to
actually enjoy just because he's got a
lid where he is dave i don't want us to
take the first thing that comes our way
we see a lot of regret in this job
market where people moved for
a paycheck
but they didn't do their whole homework
to go is this a place where i can grow
yeah we're seeing like 30 percent of
people that took new jobs in the last
two years wish they didn't that's
correct they took it for more money and
walked into a toxic environment
uh you know crazy these crazy companies
doing all this crazy stuff and they walk
into one of those things and
you know they thought the place they
used to work was everywhere and it
wasn't and so you got to watch out for
that but um so what i'm hearing if i'm
getting the details right on neil's
situation is
you know he's making 100 plus bonuses
but he's stuck he's got a ceiling
um and he's frustrated with that yep and
he should be sure okay
uh uh
but i'm not sure the right move is to
take a straight commission job that
you really don't even know if there's
any promotion yet available that's
correct and he said it kind of sounded
like yeah you can make more money and
you just move up but it's up to you you
just got to sell more
and so that does not sound like a
move that satisfies this scratches his
hitch i have a lot of questions that's
why i really challenge him to dig a
little bit more you're right this could
be a good job but is it the right job
yeah it doesn't i mean
okay so you'd go down to 75 but you
could make up to 200 someday all on
commission but none of that involved
really a promotion it really just
are working your way or developing your
leadership skills or moving up through
leadership or something like that it
just involves selling more that's
correct so let's say it gets into this
he said i don't know if i could be
passionate about it so let's just break
that down in reality he gets in starts
making money let's say he makes 200. but
he's bored he doesn't have any juice for
what he's selling the culture's not
really great doesn't see a great future
there you get you get over that paycheck
quick he shouldn't take the job i don't
think so you know and gonna be fine i'm
gonna throw another twist on see what
you think oh i like this
they offered him a straight commission
job
that's not a hard offer to make
you're right
but they are willing to hire a guy who
admittedly is not super passionate about
this
that's not somebody i want to work for
they're hiring bodies that's true
they're not doing a good job
it's absolutely this is the number one
what went through my head is i wouldn't
hire him
if he told us
oh you know i'm not super passionate
about this
uh that kind of is like ding ding then
we don't want you know we actually want
people that are like super passionate i
mean correct you know so we don't hire
people that you know i'm just really
looking for a job you know you need to
go somewhere else dude because we don't
do that here we're crusaders we're
mission driven we're passionate about
what we do all of us and you won't fit
in around here
um
and so yeah you shouldn't work for them
because i'm not sure that they're not
just throwing bodies to see what sticks
it's absolutely right a lot of leaders
do that they're going hey we just need
to fill the position and not thinking
about this and then the cost of time and
money to replace him when he leaves
really hurts the company so you got to
be careful don't take a good opportunity
take the right opportunity there's a
difference
i've actually kind of our leadership
team in the last uh three or four weeks
has slowed down our hiring here yeah
great we had a lot of positions open and
we could still fill them
but we started getting worried that we
were
adding people
that were not as jazzed and jacked up as
they should be
well you're right and the data bears
this out people have gotten on average
about a 14
bump we've had uh
48 million people folks the last 12
months 48 million people have changed
jobs in this country wow it's
extraordinary and they're doing it
because of weight it's my chance to get
paid but here's the deal if you take a
position
that you do not have any meaning in the
work there's no passion for it it
doesn't produce results that you care
about we call that mission
and then the check wears off and it will
you'll feel great for a couple of months
but then the buzz of the promotion and
the new job and the check wears off and
then you're stuck
again
i'm telling you it happens all the time
we're seeing they're calling them
boomerang employees people that are
coming back to or they're trying to
they're calling their old companies and
going hey can i come back yeah well
you may have burned a bridge there there
may not be a path back well
i'll just tell you we have a policy we
we occasionally rehire but so
occasionally our actual policy is we
almost never rehire
and the reason is that the reason you
left the first time will be the reason
you leave again
and i really don't have time for this
i'm trying to get work done that's
correct and um so you know the same
thing that buzzed you out the door
before will buzz you out again
and so there's a few times we've let
people come back very very rarely though
and some of them have worked out but in
the early days i was just like oh yeah
come on back i've got a friend that owns
a bunch of restaurants and he goes
i got people who work for me four
different times they just keep coming
back you know like a server will leave
and go to another place and the server
will go they'll go around the server
horn and end up back at the same
restaurant five years later and he goes
so we just where he his he looks at me
like i got one eye on the center of my
head when i said we don't rehire
but well he retires all the time he
don't have to spend the time and money
we do to train and properly put somebody
in there and the restaurant business is
two to three hundred percent turnover
big time so wake wicked
wicked business this is the ramsey show
[Music]
chaos
that's what it can feel like when your
business is growing so fast you've
outgrown your financial and accounting
software the faster you grow the more
likely you are to lose control of the
numbers and here's the reality if you
don't know your numbers you don't know
your business that's why we use netsuite
by oracle the number one cloud financial
system over 28 000 companies use
netsuite by oracle including ramsey
solutions because netsuite gives us a
single view of everything we need to
make daily decisions whether you're
making a few million to hundreds of
millions a year netsuite gives you the
visibility and control of the things you
need to grow like your financials
inventory hr planning budgeting and more
all in one dashboard go to netsuite.com
ramsey right now to get their free white
paper jumpstart your cfo career
[Music]
so
[Music]
ken coleman ramsey personality
number one best-selling author is my
co-host today lisa is in
phoenix hi lisa welcome to the ramsay
show
hi dave thank you
what's up
so i purchased a home in march of 2021
for 675 thousand
i did a remodel of about 200 000
and of that i had a partner my
ex-husband he donated 157 000
in the remodel and the intention was
that we would sell it in march of 2023
make a profit do that a couple more
times and then be
mortgage free
so so the issue is this month my
assessment is decided instead of waiting
until march he wants his money in august
so i have to come up with 157 000
and so my question is should i
take a home equity line of credit
out of my current home
or
should i sell one of my investment
properties which i really don't want to
do
um because i have equity in both of
those homes the home in question are you
living in it
i am okay
but your game plan your game plan was to
sell it next spring
yes
okay but the market has done some really
great husband was your husband at the
time that this all went together right
no
no no he was my ex we were just business
partners
okay that's awkward and weird um
all right um
so
i'm guessing then based on the way this
conversation is going that you two
um
did not do a partnership agreement
correct because he could not qualify you
did this on a handshake you have no
written agreement
correct
so he has no more right to decide he
wants the money now than you do to deny
it to him legally
so tell him to pound sand yes
well he has hired an attorney so good go
to court and spend a lot of money on
attorneys good that's what he's going to
have to do he's going to use up some of
his money on attorneys i guess
yeah this is what happens when you're
partners with your assessment oh my gosh
why is this not predictable um
so uh
what's the downside of selling it now
not to make him happy because there's
nothing in this conversation making me
want to make him happy
and both of you ought to have your butts
kicked for not doing a partnership
agreement that dictates the actual deal
because this would have been solved
right now it's a complete handshake and
so everybody just gets to freaking make
it up as they go
and no wonder you ended up in a
disagreement
but so what happened what's the downside
of selling it now don't you don't just
go and sell it and get out of it it
would be the capital gains i wouldn't
make the profit on it that i thought i
would and interest rates are
twice as high as what i paid before so i
would be getting a much smaller house
for probably the same payment
yeah but you're this is it's not going
to change substantially by next spring
i could sell
one of my investment properties
the reason you just gave me for selling
this house doesn't change by next spring
interest rates are not going to be back
down to 3 by spring
and you're still going to have capital
gains
in the spring
on a primary home if it's two years oh
you haven't held it yet two years no
what's the two year mark two years of
march of 2023 oh
that's the deal okay
that was the deal yeah okay
and what is his basis that he thinks
he's due this money right now
when it wasn't the agreement
he
wants me to quit claim the title over to
him and
him and me instead of just me
and because i won't do that then he's
calling
for all of his money back
yeah but that wasn't the deal
so he just thinks he can just change
deals whenever he wants
yeah
even if they're handshake deals right
yeah so he just makes up crap as he
wakes up
yeah yeah i'm curious do you think he's
hurting financially right now
uh i think he is um he also has um he's
going to get a kidney transplant so i
think he's getting worried that
um i if anything happens to him in the
surgery that i would keep his money
um
okay
so the you're absolutely that woman i
mean you just keep people's money all
the time this guy's a clown show man um
we have a son together and it would just
go to our son
hypothetically you know i wonder if he's
bluffing dave because he's hurting
financially he doesn't want to accrue a
bunch of legal fees so you owe 675 it's
worth what
1.2 million
okay um
so here's what i would here's what i
would tell him number one i would go
hire an attorney
and i would spend two thousand dollars
on that and give somebody two or five
thousand dollar retainer and say um okay
the first thing we're gonna do is we're
gonna punch this guy's lights out all
right let's start with that and then
once when he wakes up from getting
punched in the face
metaphorically speaking
um
then what we'll do is we'll say listen
if you really want out of this our deal
was real clear house was in my name that
was our deal it was going to sell in
march that was our deal you're freaking
out over your kidneys and if you want to
change the deal and you want to be
bought out early you're going to you're
going to have to do it at a discount
i'll give you 100 grand
okay
and i'll go borrow that on a home equity
loan and then you sit on this puppy and
move it in the spring
so let me just throw in i'm gonna i'm
gonna play dr john deloney for a second
this guy's been pulling your strings a
lot of years and he kind of enjoys it
and you've been letting him get away
with it and i'm listening to you
acquiesce to him on this call
yeah that's kind of what i do yeah
instead i think this is the time it
changes
this is the time you decide uh uh i'm
done with you by the way you're the
ex-husband for a reason because you're
this twerp
that's why we call you x
okay and so you don't get to call stuff
in my life you don't get to make up
stuff you don't get to jerk me around
anymore and oh by the way everybody out
there listening don't go in business
deals with your ex
just there's a reason they're an ex
so you know this is a simple simple
equation so yeah yeah lisa this is
you're just really a sweet person
and i'm more pissed off at him right now
than you are
and that's weird
so you need to you need to
metaphorically double up your fist and
say throw your shoulders back and say uh
uh i'm done
the days of you pushing this little lisa
around is done
so here's what you get bubba nothing but
an attorney bill or if you're freaking
out you want to be a bozo you want to
continue to be a clown show i'll buy you
out for 100. if you don't want to do
that let's fight
because by the time you get to court
it's going to be spring
dumb but
you know you're not even going to get
your money on you
any sooner by going to court unless he
intimidates your butt
with this that's the only way he's
getting money this does not go to trial
before spring
not a chance the courts are all backed
up with covid right now it does not go
to trial that fast so you need a good
attorney and someone that'll give you
enough information that gives you some
courage and um
and you need to put this guy in a
completely different box than you've
ever put him in before in how you handle
him going forward on issues related to
your son
because other than that you shouldn't
have any further relationship with this
guy at all
yeah call his bluff it's it's simple i
call his bluff i think he's bluffing uh
as you just admitted he's manipulated
you before he you have the leverage he
doesn't he will spend he's not going to
spend any money to fight this in court
because he doesn't have a case and he
knows it don't worry about the money
i don't think he's got that either
that's my point i'd call his bluff um
i'd hate to see you take out a home
equity line of credit when you could at
least draw a line in the sand and say no
if you can buy them out and at you know
yeah 65 cents on the dollar i'll buy
them out yeah i get it you want you want
out early but you know it says there's a
cost of that
but if you want to stay in the deal this
is what it is but here's the thing he's
not going to get any money unless you
give it to him
in any scenario before spring
yeah unless you cave absolutely that's
the line yeah because he can't get it
through courts that fast
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
six
five
four
three
[Music]
[Applause]
number one best-selling author ramsey
personality ken coleman is my co-host
today open phones at aaa 825
5225. austin's in springfield illinois
hey austin welcome to the ramsay show
hey hey dave hey ken you guys are rock
stars how are you doing today better
than we deserve sir how can we help
oh pretty good um
so i'm going to give you a little bit of
background i'm 26 years old
a couple years out of school just
started a new career about three months
ago
absolutely love it
and i just feel like i have a lot going
on in my life right now and i have
an inheritance of about six hundred
thousand dollars that my grandmother
left me
she was um she was kind of my dave
mentor before i discovered you before my
roommate showed me um your podcast and
whatnot but uh
so i'm 100 debt free never had debt ever
before and um
i'm looking to buy a house within the
next six to 12 months and
i don't know if i should be looking at
the 150 250 350 range if i should put
100 down if i should try and convert
this
non-retirement to a roth
um that's where the money is invested
it's invested in a vanguard index 500
non-retirement account okay you can't
convert it all to a roth
okay yeah not an option so that's not an
option so the only question is how much
do you leave invested how much do you
spend on the house and of course we're
going to tell you to pay cash for the
house you knew that and i got a feeling
your grandmother would tell you to pay
cash for the house
yeah definitely yeah so we'll honor her
memory
with uh with you could you with your
actions here so whatever price range
home you buy um you pay cash for and the
rest of this is investments for the
future obviously and for other things
uh you said you got a lot going on so
you got a new job
uh you've got this chunk of money that's
kind of come at you and it's a little
bit
kind of blows your mind a little bit
that you got that lay in there there's a
little bit of a stress around it
probably uh like oh god i gotta i gotta
be careful with this right
and um
so what else is going on what else makes
you a lot going on
well i'm newly single and i'm just
trying to make the right move with this
money i want to convert it out of that
non-retirement
somehow whether that's invested in real
estate i'm i'm a i'm a pretty ambitious
person i've i've always dreamed about
getting into rental properties um but i
don't know i i kind of did the math on
an excel spreadsheet and it's really
difficult to
outperform just a regular mutual fund
that you know 12 a year
unless you're really good at um you know
buying at the right price and things
like that and i feel like i would only
be
you know average
yeah
well i i i think the first thing is you
decide on a home you nearly single you
get been through a divorce
no no just um a breakup breakup okay all
right cool
well i i think um
you're buying a bachelor pad
um so um
the thing i would recognize when you're
buying this property
is that if when you do meet someone in
the future and
uh they become your wife you will
discover that you bought the wrong house
and you get to make you get to trade it
in for the one that she thinks is a
better idea
um so this is just for you for a few
years here
uh probably
statistically speaking i'm not saying
you have to follow that path but
um
you know that that so uh
buy something that's um
uh conservative and that would be easy
to resell
and that you get some joy out of in the
short term
and that could be that could be a condo
in a cool location
okay i'm more of an acreage kind of guy
it could be some acreage there where you
got some room maybe a double wide or
something uh no no no
not a double no that goes down in value
we're buying things that go up in value
but yeah if you get some acreage that's
fine and a little cabin on it or
something as long as it's something that
you can
visualize reselling easily it's not a
such a weird property that it's hard to
sell
are you handy austin like would you do
some of the work in some of this this
future see i wonder dave if if this is a
chance for him to go all right i got to
learn how to do this you learned how to
do it buying the right house could he
buy something in the 150 or less that
has a lot of potential that it's his
he's got some acreage it's still the
bachelor pad it's not a dump i wonder if
he could kind of ease into this because
he's paying cash it becomes an
investment property whatever you're
going to do pay cash and as far as the
investment rentals go later take your
time
and don't pay full price you don't make
money on rental real estate that you pay
full price for
it's the returns as you said the returns
are not good on that
so um i simply do not buy investment
real estate at appraised value period
i just don't do it
um
i say i don't there's very rare
exceptions i think one time i did but
you know but the numbers just don't work
because you're paying your you know your
return on investment when you pay cash
for it is not great enough to screw with
it um you're better off as he said do
mutual funds usually but a
well-purchased piece of property
including its future appreciation
including its tax deductions due to
depreciation those three things together
called the internal rate of return will
far exceed
the uh rate of return on mutual fund but
it's a lot more hassle too is there a
price range dave is there a price range
if you were giving some advice and they
had cash and they did it the way that we
teach and so they is there price range
where you can get deals right now or is
every basic size if you look at your you
know 1500 square feet 25 35 whatever is
there a price range or a certain size
that's a good deal
bargains are not on every corner got it
you can find you can find is still very
very hot
grants in baltimore hey grant welcome to
the ramsey show
all right how are you doing today great
man what's up
oh not too much so uh calling because
i've got a you know somewhat similar
question away that you turned to two at
the end i'm uh you know sell real estate
on the younger guy and uh you know have
a good amount of cash saved up make it
you know decent living how much cash
i've led a couple of
about six hundred thousand dollars way
to go good for you
yeah yeah so um and i've let a couple
investments you know go by that you know
i live at home with my parents you know
because we work out of the house and uh
if i'm gonna hold on to the place for
you know basically forever for the full
27 years of depreciation
does it make sense for me to buy
something now and pay a little bit more
knowing that i'm gonna hold on to it and
not be you know a thousand dollars
positive a month no just because you
know
okay that's what we were just talking
about don't buy the investment property
and pay full price for it
yeah take your time okay take your time
okay
now i'm okay if you're gonna buy a home
to live in
and you pay retail for it that's not the
end of the world
uh but but you know you're
you you have nothing pushing you here
except just your ambition
yeah and so just the money in real
estate is made at the buy
that's when you make your money in real
estate at the buy
and then you collect it monthly and you
collect it big time on the resale
someday
but the money is made at the buy i
bought a bunch of stuff in 2008 for 15
20 cents on the dollar
and man don't you think i'm smiling
right now on that stuff
because of what i paid for it because
the 2008 crash right i got it was a bar
is bargain city man it was everywhere
and um i only turned one of those pieces
of property and it was a dump and it's
still a dump the guy that bought it from
me is still a dump it was a nasty piece
of commercial but
um
my son-in-law winston hated that
property he manages our property he's
like i hate this building so you it's a
building you're not allowed to hate
buildings it's just fair it's a
conference
no i hate this building when i drive
near it my heart rate changes i'm like
all right let's get rid of it so we sold
it but anyway that most of the time you
buy it and you hold it but it's even
sweeter and sweeter and sweeter and your
cash on cash returns all those kinds of
things that you're looking at
are based on the buy the money in real
estate is made at the buy
so do not
pay only by investment real estate where
you're paying cash and do not under any
circumstances
pay full price for it just take your
time
yeah take your time yeah i you know
years ago i'm spying ken back in 40
years ago i was buying properties that's
what a different living then um
i was i would buy some from this little
local bank
and the guy called me up one day and he
goes hey i've got a guy that's in a
situation he needs to get rid of this
house and okay
and he goes you know ramsay you're a
vulture
and i went yeah he goes but you're the
nicest vulture oh the nice kind yeah so
i'm the nice kind of one right yeah i'm
but i'm always circling and i'm patient
i'm swooping in to help people i'm
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
hey folks ken coleman here did you know
the ramsay show is one of the most
popular podcasts in the world it's your
daily dose of advice on life and money
check out all of our shows from the
ramsey network wherever you listen to
podcasts
[Music]
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsey show where
debt is dumb cash is king and the paid
off home mortgage has taken the place of
the bmw as the status symbol of choice
we help people build wealth do work that
they really love and create actual
amazing relationships this is the ramsay
show ken coleman number one best-selling
author host of the ken coleman show
ramsey personality is my co-host today
isabella in nashville starts off this
hour hi isabella how are you
i'm great how are you better than i
deserve what's up
yes sir
um so growing up my family always
struggled financially so it was a
personal goal of mine to graduate
college debt free good um i'm such a
graduate debt free in may at 19 years
old
and whoa i currently 19.
yes what's your degree in um finance and
how did you do this so fast
um i tested out of a lot so all my gen
eds and everything were done when i
graduated high school nice yeah you're
an ap queen huh
yes sir club testing dual enrollment
everything yeah way to go girl you
killed it way to go
so at 19 you're going to come out with a
degree in finance in may a year from now
uh yes sir and then i hope to go back
for a master's in actuarial science but
yeah that'll take you about 30 minutes
the way you do stuff so yeah okay cool
yes sir um
so i'm currently working as a bank
teller and i also volunteer with a
non-profit that'll pay for my sister's
dance um
because
i live with my extremely generous
parents i only have a few expenses
so right now my current financial
situation is that i have 25 000 in the
bank right now and i keep putting about
90 percent of my paycheck in there
my question is
should i keep saving my paycheck or
should i consider other options like
investing right now
wow you're amazing
okay
thank you you're just so far ahead of
the curve
so it sounds like it sounds like
yeah it sounds like 25 years old six
years from now
is um
light years away for you that sounds
like it's a long ways away
but at 25 years old six years from now
you will still be young
very young and by then you'll have a
huge polycash so
um
you're just an overachiever there's no
question about it so i don't i don't
want to
hold you back on the one hand but on the
other hand i want you to it's okay to i
want you to have permission to
have some patience
so i i i think you
are the best possible investment you can
make
because you're pretty amazing
so what i mean is i think every dollar
you spend on this masters
is going to give you a lot higher rate
of return than any investment would ever
give you
especially you i
yes sir i hope to get scholarships for
that i know i know and i i hope you do
too i hope you do too but here's the
thing let's pretend you go through your
masters and you're 22 years old 21 years
old and you come out and you get the
first big girl job
and you're making 100 000 or 80 000
bucks or whatever and you got 75 000 in
the bank
and you never invested any of it before
then
and you start your investing life at the
ripe old age of 22.
you're gonna be just fine and that 75
000 that 25 000 is going to be upped by
a bunch because you're a saver and
you're watching this it's just your
insurance policy
that you get to go be all you're
supposed to be because i don't want
money standing in your way
so
thank you that's a huge compliment yeah
i want you to be able to write checks
and even if you went and got an
apartment or something
a little bit later you don't have to do
that
at this stage of the game but if you did
that and you spent some of the money on
that and i don't want you to blow the
money i'm not telling you to you know go
buy a 40 000 car don't do that i'm not
telling you do anything like that i'm
just saying that big old pile of cash is
an insurance policy that isabella
finishes her masters with no debt and no
stress and gets to run the track that
she can run on because you're so
efficient at your education and then
when you come out you're going to be
i mean you're going to be kicking butt
and taking names mathematically
and you dump it into an investment then
or dump it into your first house then or
whatever if you don't use it and you
probably won't use it
but i just love the idea that you don't
have to think about money
okay thank you and you can concentrate
on
your studies and your track because
you're
you're you know you're way over
achieving it's awesome yeah you're going
you're going to be by the time you're 30
this is all going to be like boring
yeah well i love what i do i i love my
job and i love school so
yeah yeah well and you're obviously you
know you're you're very uh
goal-oriented you like standing stuff up
and knocking it down
exactly yeah yeah i'm just curious
what's the dream you don't want to you
don't want to stop it being a teller oh
no sure where do you want to go
well that's what um i want to be an
actuary and then
like farther along i'd love to teach
like a college course or something like
that's something i'd love to do yeah
okay great probably do that this week
yeah
wow
oh man yeah well your advice gives her
options and just it's it just is really
nice to have that big old giant
pile of cash as she continues to evolve
dream see opportunities there's going to
be opportunities that come to her
that
our people bang on the door of people
like her oh yeah they stand out they go
hey
she's going to get opportunities she'll
never even see coming i mean you know i
i think you're going to be bored to
death as an actuary
you you because you just have i mean
that that's a that's a number crunch 24
7 job yeah and it's a wonderful job
there's nothing wrong with it but you
are so task oriented goal oriented
that i i think you know about a week of
that you'll be done with it i could be
wrong that's just an old guy looking in
from the outside impressed way to go
kiddo proud of you if we can help you
let us be a part of your life as you go
forward holler anytime we'd be honored
to to speak and and have a tiny bit to
just to say we know who you are you're
pretty cool open phones at triple eight
eight two five
five two two five so ken you can't go to
college without a student loan
isabella says hold my beer
right that's right and you know you know
of course
our very own christina ellis is a genius
on all this stuff but i'm telling you
something uh for this gal to clep out of
all these courses i can't even spell
clep you know what i mean well yeah me
and you didn't clap out of nothing
so she clef she she advances the whole
thing mom and dad helping her out uh
living at home swallowing her pride not
trying to be like everybody else i mean
all the things great parents taught her
the ways to go and now all of a sudden
for her to sit here not only does she
have unbelievable financial potential as
everybody was listening that's going wow
but professional potential as well
there's no holding her dreams back
because she can fund them well most 19
year olds are clipping out of beer pong
i mean really yeah and here she's
already graduated from college oh yeah
this is like savant stuff yeah it's
cray-cray i love it
so fun
so fun her mom and dad just walking
around proud
yeah they're just grinning yeah no
student loan debt
this is just
yeah
it's it's isabella's world we're all
just kind of hanging out
[Laughter]
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Applause]
life is full of firsts
[Music]
as the first and longest serving
christian health cost sharing ministry
chm has shared medical expenses for its
members since 1981.
we believe you should have the freedom
to focus on your health while being
supported by a community of believers
giving you the opportunity to create
many more firsts
[Music]
so
so
[Music]
ken coleman ramsey personality number
one best-selling author is my co-host
today a lot of people rather spend their
weekend doing yard work than talk about
insurance
matter of fact they'd rather do just
about anything than talk about insurance
i can't really blame you
here's the deal though if you don't
learn about insurance you will continue
to get screwed by insurance
there is good insurance and bad
insurance and you just have to have a
little bit of knowledge around it around
here we think learning about money
topics should be simple
and even sometimes fun
our new confidence in your coverage a
five-day video series makes learning
about insurance quick and practical it
is not all day long it's just a few
minutes each day five different clips in
other words and you might even laugh out
loud a time or two because it is after
all our own ramsey personality george
campbell doing it and you'll always get
a chuckle when george is around at the
end of the series you'll still have the
yard work but at least you'll know your
stuff when it comes to insurance it is
free go to ramseysolutions.com
confidence
ramsay solutions
dot com
slash confidence and get confidence in
your coverage a five-day video series
for free our question of the day comes
from blinds.com they have a 100
satisfaction guarantee that means even
if you mismeasure you pick the wrong
color they'll remake your blinds for
free free samples free shipping new
promos all the time you'll save even
more use the promo code ramsey
today's question comes from trevor in
california i'm 28 years old single on
baby step four and earn 400 000 a year
how do i leave the golden handcuffs of a
lucrative career in tech sales to
transition to a career in luxury excuse
me luxury residential real estate this
is my true passion but i have no idea
where to start
well he's making really really good
money but dave the challenge with moving
uh into
real estate whether it's luxury or a
luxury i don't know why i'm struggling
with that word or regular uh homes if
you will is you can't do it part-time
i've talked a lot of experts i don't
know if you defer on that opinion but
you kind of at some point have to go all
in uh in real estate sales now he's
making a lot of good money so he could
save a good chunk and kind of pad his
stats if you will so that when he goes
to luxury real estate he's all in and
he's not really hurting for money but
that's a save and then get qualified
and then dive in
but i i don't know i you know luxury
real estate's a whole different ball
game very exclusive you know more about
that than than i do as far as how unique
that particular side of real estate
sales is yeah i mean it you don't just
dive into that do you you know you is
gonna work your way up you can you've
got you don't have to start selling
cheap houses to sell expensive houses
but you've got you've got to have some
knowledge of that marketplace and
knowledge of dealing with that type of
clientele
so what i would do
um is i would join a luxury real estate
team
part-time yeah and get your get your
license under you get your you know get
some of the prereqs the legal prereqs
behind you
get out there be moving around do some
transactions on a part-time basis
because the good news about residential
real estate is you generally work for a
situation like this it's not it's not
good news overall but good news you
generally work when others don't
because people can't look at a house
during the day
even luxury sometimes they can if
they're you know they're transferring
whatever but i mean they're gonna look
at houses at nights and weekends
and so
the exception of somebody coming in from
out of town or whatever that kind of
thing but uh you know you can you can
use some of your pto you can do some
other stuff work around and uh you know
just work a 40-hour week as all at your
current position
and take your nights and weekends and
the occasional
vacation time and you know take six
months and
get up on the on-ramp a little smoother
rather than just jumping off the high
dive and hoping there's water in the
pool that's exactly right yeah yeah and
then but but it is going to end up being
where you have you're probably not going
to get the boat as close to the dock as
i would like correct meaning your luxury
real estate income up to close enough to
your tech before you make the jump
you're probably going to have to do the
thing you're talking about there's a
little bit of a step of faith there but
just going cold turkey it takes six
months three months just to get up and
moving that's correct and you can do all
of that on a part-time basis much more
efficiently and not lose that chunk of
income that's correct while you're doing
that but yeah i think you make the
transition i it's
it's a weird time to do it uh the good
thing about the real estate market
slowing down is
all these people that just went and got
the real estate license because real
estate was easy yeah they're gonna fall
off they're the first ones to leave last
in first out
and so uh it it it calls out the
under producers it calls out a hard time
a recession
a slower real estate market calls out
the agents that are not rock stars that
are not the best of the best and so
because you got to pay
to keep
the licenses the re you know the realtor
fees the mls fees all that stuff it
costs if you don't if you're not making
money in the business it's not something
you can just park it and sit there
uh so it does it really does push people
out of the business in times like this
so it is a good time to make this
transition
versus trying to jump in while
everybody's riding these wave it's like
you know lately has been like going
surfing in the middle of a hurricane
i mean it's just there's a lot of waves
so open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two five marshals in
phoenix hey marshall how are you
hey i'm doing great how you doing dave
better than we deserve what's up
hey uh first of all i just wanted to say
thank you so much for everything you and
the team do
um it's uh been a real inspiration to me
i've made a lot of progress i started
off uh the start of the year um i came
across one of your videos on youtube and
just kind of decided i was sick and
tired of living paycheck to paycheck and
never having money in the bank
um and uh
worked off
paying off about four thousand dollars
in credit card debt and about seven
thousand an auto loan and now i've got
left is some student loans that i've
kind of pushed paused on while i get
ready to pay for a wedding good for you
yeah so how can we help today
express my gratitude for that but uh i
am currently in school for uh getting my
bachelor's degree in accounting um i had
originally started this degree back
before i had gotten divorced
because my ex-wife and i were planning
to get into business together
and i'm
almost done with i'm six classes from
completing my degree and i just don't
know
how to get out of my current position i
work at wells fargo
and
i work in their mortgage team i've been
trying to get into a more
accounting side of things
which maybe because i don't have my
degree it's not going to happen but um
i'm not sure what to do with my degree
once i get it because um my original
purpose for getting the degree is no
longer
an option where do you want to go you
want to i'm confused do you want to stay
in it i want to get into accounting or
some completely different fields yeah i
i'd like to get into accounting or
finance or
well you've got you're about ready to
finish an accounting degree
so you got that
am i am i right
yeah yeah and a lot of the jobs i've
been kind of perusing um within uh wells
fargo um
looks like they want several years of
experience and they look like
what i would estimate to be entry-level
jobs
so
any advice on how to
get into
that field once i do complete my degree
yeah well we start now so you start now
making connections with people that are
actually successful in accounting your
relationships is where opportunities
come the second thing is i'd be very
very careful to look for jobs that
aren't available to you at this point in
where you are so you don't have any real
experience so you don't look for jobs
that will require a bunch of experience
and i hear this a lot well it says it's
entry level but it requires experience
and
that's not always the case and i can
tell you this we're seeing people
getting accounting jobs bookkeeping jobs
all over the place without a degree but
you're going to have the degree so this
is all about looking to places that are
looking for somebody to come right in
and do work now you might be surprised
that you could get a job in an
accounting firm doing some entry-level
basic accounting
part-time work because they need extra
hands but right now this is all about
relationships um i'm gonna give you the
book the proximity principle it's the
number one bestseller
this is a clear plan for you to leverage
relationships and connections to get
opportunities well before you get the
degree
and don't work for a bank there's a lot
more opportunity out there than that
yeah this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
look i love real estate and i want you
to have a house but i don't want a house
to have
you
that's why you need to get in touch with
churchill mortgage to make sure you do
this right these guys are awesome
they'll help you get on a smarter
mortgage plan because they're committed
to doing what's right for
you
that means they check in every year with
free consultations to help you stay on
the right plan they show you how to save
money and interest so you can build
wealth faster they walk you through the
total cost of your loan so you can make
the best choice
basically they care that's why we call
them ramsey trusted you can achieve
debt-free home ownership and churchill
is here to help go to their site
churchillmortgage.com
ramsey to start your approval or get
more information
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
ken coleman ramsey personality is my
co-host today thank you for joining us
america this is the ramsey show zach is
with us in utah hi zach welcome to the
ramsay show
hi dave how are you great man what's up
hey um i'm a new listener to the show i
started listening in in january this
year i've heard i heard of dave ramsey
but i i finally started listening to the
show in january
and uh my wife and i became obsessed so
we've paid off um all of our debt now
except for our house
um great significant amount of debt we
had quite a bit of debt we weren't we
weren't following your principles
but we're now flying through the baby
steps paid off 283 000
in debt so far this year
and um that's ridiculous
amazing yeah
yeah it feels really good did you sell
one of your kids how did you do that
we we've been fortunate we've been
blessed to have a really good income and
i've always been a favor and um
we just we didn't have a structure or a
strategy and so the baby steps we say we
bought into your program and
and uh attacked it with with as much
intensity as we could well you're doing
great how can we help today
thank you so um
we're in a position now
where all we have left is our mortgage
and we actually have enough saved almost
exactly to pay off the mortgage
today but that wouldn't leave us with
any sort of emergency fund and so
anyway
the goal is my goal is to get my wife
and my four kids we want to be
at your studio doing our complete debt
free stream by the end of the year i'm
just wondering
what you would recommend as far as how
much of an emergency fund i should have
before we go ahead and pay off the house
okay wow
what's the balance on the house
uh
390 000 somewhere in there and you have
that in savings
i do and you paid off 283 000
i have what do you make
uh
about a half million a year
okay
that still doesn't do those numbers
that's amazing
you've been doing that you've been doing
this more than since january then or you
already had savings well well you've
sold something saving more than since
january yes yeah okay
all right wow we've had a good income
for a lot of years we just we just
haven't followed your your your program
we were kind of done with that we had a
home equity line of credit with a you
know a bunch of debt that we didn't need
okay and uh that well let's uh let's
just i mean we can play around with all
kinds of numbers the rule of thumb on
the emergency fund is three to six
months
of expenses
obviously if your house is paid off your
expenses are lower
but you need some money laying around so
when life happens and so it's a
grandma's rainy day fund right
that's what that is right in your world
um
i mean your expenses are going to be
fairly low
uh
so i i mean i would think 20 or 30
probably thirty thousand bucks i'm just
making that up
um
that ought to cover you for a serve for
more than three months shouldn't it
i well
that would make me nervous i've never
had
that little okay so what would you what
would you like for your emergency fund
to be
uh well i i mean
the thing that makes me the most nervous
my my job it's been really good but it's
it's always changing it's a 100
commission job
and
so that's kind of why i'm so what does
it take to operate your household
everything included taxes
uh property taxes insurance groceries
what's it take to operate your household
for a month
i would say
probably
i'm new to this debt being paid off but
i'd say probably at least 6 000 a month
okay
so three of those would be 18
six of those would be 36.
okay so i said 30.
uh if you want to say 40 it doesn't need
to be 80.
okay
so i you know okay
anywhere 30 to 50 is going to be good
with me
uh that sounds like it's about that you
know because you want some extra cushion
and i'm good with that but i mean and
we're going to add to the fact that your
income is somewhat valid or potentially
volatile so if we do that how long does
it take you let's call it 40 just for
discussions purposes okay
so that means you're if you if you hold
40 aside and you throw everything else
at the mortgage you got a 40 000 balance
on the mortgage
right right
how fast you pay that off
by christmas one month i i could do that
one month well i could do that next
month okay yeah well let's do that yeah
yeah just just write them a check right
now for everything by 40 whole 40 back
and next month send them a check for 40
and be done
okay i was i was thinking maybe waiting
until i had
all plus the emergency fund and then
paying out but you'd recommend no i just
because here's what this is doing it's
it's get it's getting you
because you you're deriving more uh
peace from this pile of money than you
are from the debt-free house
and i want to move you toward i want to
move that peace location over to the
debt-free house so i'm going to go and
throw all this money by 40 at that and
get you used to having 40 in the account
oh and by the way by christmas you're
gonna have a lot more than 40 in the
account because you're going to keep
saving because you can't keep yourself
from doing it right
okay we'll get her done yeah yeah so
congratulations man what do you do for a
living thank you
uh i uh run a sales team solar is what
we do wow yeah solar in utah yeah big
big business yeah wow good for you
he's killing it that's wonderful yeah i
mean amazing to be able to save that
amount of money
so i don't know that this is true today
but i have heard
throughout my 40
plus year working life
that overall
one of the best paid
positions
anywhere is sales
that's still correct
absolutely because there's guys like
that or guys like we had a minute ago
that we wanted to go to luxury real
estate but was in making bank and tech
sales
or you got guys and gals that are
pharmaceutical sales 200 300 a year
you've got a medical device sales 2 300
300 a year
you've got um
real estate sales you know yeah here's
one for you that you don't even think
about just to illustrate your point
played golf with a guy the other day
makes big crazy money you know what he
sells those giant
pipes that you see along the side of the
road when you put a development in it's
all about moving water but somebody
sells those things you know and they're
big dollars because you think about
construction companies or governments
are paying for those things yeah and
he's the guy who makes the deal and he's
selling those things there you go
and here here's another interesting
thing
the number of sales and marketing people
that end up being presidents of
companies
higher greater than a lot of other
positions the
is a natural flow of things and so a guy
like what zack's doing he's got
my point is he's not only making bank
but he's got tremendous upside potential
even from that so
um
yeah sales is not a um
it is not a uh a negative career path by
any stretch no
yeah you can do very very well there
ryan's in knoxville hey ryan welcome to
the ramsey show
thanks for having me sure what's up
uh so i have recently been uh given a
job opportunity that
when you compare salaries compared to my
current job it pays more but after
reviewing benefits it seems like it
possibly could be
a pay cut but this job is doing
something more along the lines of what i
want to do versus what i'm currently
doing which is
not necessarily what i want to do
what's the long-term potential on this
um it is with a private company that is
been growing for over the last five
years and is projected to to grow more
and with that their teams and
opportunities will continue to grow and
it's the kind of work you want to be
doing
uh yes it's it's a lot more along the
lines
of what i what i want
dave what do you think i i tend to take
i'd bet on myself if it's really where
you want to be long term and i'd fix my
budget a little bit to absorb that if
you feel like you're going to make more
in the short term
yeah it um
i guess the question is how much is
difference isn't it is it a 30 000 year
difference or a 3 000 of your difference
yeah don't take the big difference we're
talking a little bit 3 000 of your
difference shut up and go do the new
thing you know stop your whining uh if
it's a 30 000 then maybe you need to
rethink it yeah say pass yeah
this is the ramsey show
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
ken coleman ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones a triple eight
eight two five five
two two five
so ken as a uh certified capitalist pig
are you saying about me or you me oh and
you i was gonna say i wanted to be
included in yeah okay well we're we'll
we'll be uh we will be co-pigs there it
is there it is and uh but in that case
what i uh
never want someone to do in career and i
want to get your professional career
uh input on this
is i have seen too many people trade
a wonderful income potential and or
wonderful income
for one of two things or both
and i think the trade was a bad trade
thing one is
i will make less because i work for uh
because it's uh the company or the the
institution is stable
like i'm gonna take a state job right as
an auditor and i'm gonna make 75 cents
on the dollar of what i could make in an
accounting firm as an auditor but it's
stable
bullcrap
number one okay number two is
i i don't want to leave
the benefits package or i i i don't want
to i'll go i'll work for less
because i can go over there for the
benefits package like you know i had i
actually had a person tell me one time i
mean this is how people's brains get
screwed up on this
they they were paying for their own
health insurance it was eight hundred
dollars a month which is ten thousand
dollars a year
and they took a job
making thirty thousand dollars less
because the health care was free
right
i'm like that ain't free dude that's
right you just lost 20 grand yeah
you know i mean yeah you got rid of a 10
000 expense but you also got rid of 30
000 worth your income so that's a bad
and people don't do math
well
on the risk differentiation to the quote
stable job and they don't do math well
sometimes not everybody but some people
don't
on the
the benefits package i get this grunt
over you know my benefits package it's
like
yeah but you make nothing that's correct
uh well first of all i completely agree
if you go the stability route you're
settling
and and you've just already you've just
sold yourself and your future and your
potential you've sold it out because you
said i'm gonna take what is safe what is
stable and what you're really saying is
i'm gonna settle because i'm afraid to
put myself out there and deal with
change when change happens that's number
one on this other issue on benefits it's
odd dave because they'll end up choosing
a benefit that doesn't benefit them
financially yeah it's an oxymoron like
you chose this job over benefits
but it didn't benefit you and you're
exactly right you know uh for years
before i came to work at rmg solutions
station i ran a small business just
stacey and i together
and we had to pay for health care
ourselves but we we had no other
expenses it was just us so we were able
to make with straight commissioned sales
as you know we sold sponsorships to live
good money in those years well but the
bottom line is yeah it was it was crazy
to see the cost of it but it didn't
matter because we made so much more
working for ourselves and we had no
other overhead at all so you've got to
look at the whole kind of peel the whole
onion there and like you said and don't
make a decision based on safety because
many times there's fear
that is clouding your judgment anyway so
you're absolutely right don't make a
decision on benefits well and the thing
is it's not safer that's correct
because of the trade you traded a bunch
of income that would have given you more
safety than the stability gave you
correct i mean if you if you if you give
up 300 dollars over a period of years
in order to quote be safe if you'd had
that three hundred thousand dollars in
your pocket you would have been safer
than
working in this toxic environment where
people are underperforming that's
correct because they all ran to safety
too so uh one of the things i grew up in
a straight commission household mom and
dad were in the real estate business and
so they always taught us that your only
safety is in your ability to go get the
next thing amen
and so if you have the ability to go get
another thing you're safe so you are
your safety
your skill keeping your skills sharp
keeping them current stay on top of
things you're only as safe as your
ability to land the next deal that's
correct you have to believe in you and
not let fear dictate your decisions we
have so much fear in this country and
really around the globe and this is an
example where you'll take a bad job or
you won't leave a government job where
you've never gotten promoted or if you
get promoted at all it's very little you
have no opportunity for growth and
you're absolutely right dave the amount
of money that you you've passed up on is
silly so the safe choice is silly
and and and i get this question a lot
and
people trade doing something they love
for that oh yeah they'll take the safe
thing that they hate right over the
thing that feels risky to them so i go
into business for myself i'm selling
books out of the trunk of my car
my sweet grandmother
my grandpa my grandpa was one of my
heroes grandpa ramsey was one of my
heroes he was just a wonderful man
uh but he lost a business in the great
depression went to work for alcoa
aluminum in accounting worked there 38
years was head cost account when he left
so he had worked his way up he'd done
very well there had a great career
but uh he never would do anything else
because of the fear that the scars of
having lost the other thing
and um and plus she wasn't gonna have
him do anything else oh yeah she wanted
the safety the security of freaking
alcoa aluminum right i didn't want to
sleep on the couch right and so uh
so he has passed away at this point and
i've opened this business and i'm
selling the books out of the trunk of my
car my grandmother's call me up are you
okay
are y'all okay
are y'all okay and i'll never forget
when i when i sold my one millionth
financial piece book wow
um she called up and she said
i'm just worried when are you gonna get
a real job
that's classic
a million books
but she didn't understand no i mean
no she's sweet as she could be i'm not
running her down and i'm not disparaging
her memory she's one of my favorite
people
but it's just that's that mentality of
you know i got a lot of security from
that million book sales
yeah
just say the least yeah
like
anyway
yeah uh uh yeah
you know what she was saying though she
was saying i don't understand what you
do i don't know what this is and it's
scary
it's scary what we do not know we fear
yeah the the entrepreneurial
journey for
that is a super scary for a person it's
not that so but our my point is not
everybody has to be an entrepreneur not
everybody's seven million books that's
not what we're talking about what we're
talking about is that last caller made
me think of this he he's like i don't
know man the benefits package is not as
good
and and he was actually in his case
doing math to his credit he was he said
you know actually he's going to cost me
more that's right for my health
insurance i get a raise but after i pay
more for the health insurance i'm not
actually probably making a little a
little less that's right which is why i
took it to him and said and this is the
question you all have to answer in the
same scenario if i take a temporary if
it's if i look at my overall budget and
it's a little bit less i only do that if
it's not a cost it's an investment so if
he takes this job and let's say six
months from the time he takes it's a
good chance he's gonna get a nice bump
or he starts making more or within six
months to a year he's positioned for
promotion to make way more now that
becomes not a cost but an investment
yeah at which point you would change
your budget it's why we that's why we
have every dollar here's something
a 401k
you have to put the money in the 401k
that's correct so you get to decide yeah
and the company might or might not match
so the match is the only actual
financial benefit correct you can do a
a retirement plan if you don't have a
401k roth ira right
that you put the money into now there's
no match obviously there but if your
your new company has no match
and you currently have no match
you can't go i'm going over there
because they have a 401k that's correct
because it does it's zero it's worth
zero
that's true it's not worth it cause
they're not matching you're not getting
the match now you're not getting a match
then both of them are your dollars going
in why correct but people get in their
head that that's a benefit package now
most companies today do match so that's
you know you're gonna find that but but
even that don't take a three percent
match on a 401k
and then take a fifteen thousand dollar
pay cut
that's right and call that a gain
because it's not that's correct you're
not making that much you gotta look into
the numbers what does it actually mean
what's the short-term decision that best
gets me to where we want to be long-term
always is the where can i make the most
money doing what i love that's right and
the rest of it figure it out that's
right but i mean
sell a million books and you don't worry
about i mean go go make more money and
you will find your safety there you can
buy benefits with more money yeah
that's the thing so don't just don't
make these trades they're bad trades
y'all and you know you don't have to be
an entrepreneur to do that
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
dave here you can find all of our shows
with the ramsey network app on your
smartphone it's the only place to listen
to the entire back catalog of episodes
download the ramsey network app in your
favorite app store today
[Music]
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsey show where
debt is dumb cash is king and the paid
off home mortgage has taken the place of
the bmw as the status symbol of choice
this is the ramsey show we help people
build wealth do work that they really
love and create amazing relationships
get coleman ramsey personality number
one best-selling author is my co-host
today and this hour is a blast
we get to talk with people who have
successfully
become wealthy
uh one way to gauge that is your net
worth when you have a net worth of a
million dollars or more you are called a
millionaire
a millionaire is not someone that makes
a million dollars a year
your net worth is defined as
your income or your income your assets
minus your liabilities what you own
minus what you owe
equals your net worth when you have that
number be a million dollars you are a
millionaire well i don't feel like i'm
it's not a feeling well no one should
have that much wealth it's not a moral
construct it is a freaking math formula
and when i hear some of these
politicians go well he makes a million
dollars a year he's a millionaire it
just makes me want to my mind explode
because they don't even know what
they're talking about there's only one
definition a millionaire
only one
when you have a net worth of a million
dollars or greater that's all we're
going to talk about and here's the
interesting thing we've done the largest
study of millionaires in north america
ever done
10
167 millionaires
interviewed
more than statistically sound
more than statistically significant
airtight research
and we have data to back this up and we
started doing this hour a few years ago
talking to actual millionaires some of
them became millionaires from
inheritance some of them became
millionaires from luck some of them
became millionaires from hard work and
saving some of them became millionaires
by following the baby steps we call
those baby steps millionaires and
we wrote a book about it that's the
number one bestseller that has the study
of the millionaires in the back of it
and so it's a great book to read to go
along with all this so ken we're going
to take calls this hour only from real
millionaires and find out how they
really did it because everybody's got an
opinion but let's talk to the real guy
yeah and this is the place where we
celebrate millionaires not put guilt on
them for being greedy
you know i forgot about that you're
supposed to be ashamed
but we're not and we're not we are not
ashamed and we are not ashamed of you
we're happy for you if you inherited it
if you won the lottery if you worked
your tail off if you started i don't
care what you did as long as you didn't
steal it then we're going to celebrate
you as being a millionaire stephen is
our first millionaire up this hour
stephen is in winston-salem north
carolina stephen what is your net worth
just shy of 4 million right now cool
way to go man that's awesome so uh how
old are you
i am 62 you and i are the same age about
two months apart i love it many times so
very cool so give me the breakdown on
the 4 million how does it break out real
estate investments and what
about 2.6 in retirement about 200 in
cash outside of retirement about 950 000
in a paid for beach house and our
primary residence
way to go good good for you love it
that's a great breakdown by the way okay
so how much of this did you inherit
i think i inherited 5000 when my dad
died we bought a dining room table with
it
what i inherited from my dad was work
ethic and do whatever it takes there you
go i like that that's a good inheritance
if you got to choose that's the best
kind
uh and so and uh what was your range of
income during your working lifetime the
last 40 years or so what was your best
year household income and worst year
well probably worst year probably down
as low as 15 000
by best year or somewhere between 150
and 200 thousand okay and what you do
for a living or do you do it for a
living well i'm self-employed so i do
i'm a flooring inspector i do forensics
for flooring warranties so okay what do
you have a four-year degree
i have a master's in business and a
four-year degree and i took a
two-month-old baby to class for three
and a half years to get that four-year
degree
so what was your gpa in college
probably about three point
eight in graduate or excuse me an
undergraduate probably about the same to
graduate
wow i'll show off that's impressive 3.8
so are you guys uh are you guys tv
people or book people at night
well i don't watch much tv if i watch tv
it'll be a video because i can't see
what's on
all tv i'll go with that
and uh i travel a lot so i do a lot of
books in the car yeah so can this still
be done if somebody's out there 25 years
old and listening to you and me
i wish i would have started back last
one
i started when i was 46.
wow okay so you think it can still be
done now
oh yes all day long what do you think
they should do if they want to be you
when they grow up
well yeah so i think warren buffett said
you know you have to pay yourself first
and then live within your means and make
some smart investments and just do it
like the turtles
you know
short and slow and sweet and steady wow
so you said you started at 46. i think a
lot of people would love to hear what
the starting point looked like where
were you financially when you started
this path at 46.
okay well let me go to a little bit of
background with dave because
the yeah my wife and i want to start
them i had two businesses at the time at
a carp cleaning company that i started
and then a year later started the
business at home now
and about three days for our 22nd
anniversary my wife decided to move out
and
we went through council for a little bit
the divorce filed the next year had a
pastor and his wife devote nine months
of their time to get our marriage back
together
and so we renew our vows so the first
time i met dave this is back way many
years ago in knoxville we did the vip
tickets we got to eat lunch with you
sharon and the kids
wow and
then we went back that year and did the
financial counselor training together
that was the class where the one
teammate lost a wife and a child in the
car accident oh yeah
you came out to talk to us during lunch
had your team member features in the
newsletter and i went back that year and
did entree leadership you know i had
dinner or lunch a couple times there at
the vanderbilt marriott when you were
doing entree leadership yeah that was a
long time ago
oh yeah
this is 20 years ago yeah oh yeah and
then you know you sent a crew
just to make her recruit our house about
three years ago right before everyday
millionaires launched and they spent a
day with us an entire day so my
granddaughter actually she half her life
she's lived with us and she got to be in
the second half of the video so we
a long time and you've been following
our story
yeah so you you remember me if you saw
me because so you're oh i
know who you are so you're not now that
you brought all that up because i've
seen the videos the uh so you truly are
a baby steps millionaire and you started
at 46. from bro correct
and our my one of my 25th anniversary
gifts to my wife when we got back
together
well i had to lie to her because you
know i told lord forgive me for mine but
we i had already set up a
meeting at our small group leader's
house and she thought we were going
there for something after church
and i actually had her dad come down
from pennsylvania to get her sister and
georgia brought them up so they were
running behind so i had to kind of lie
to her and say hey i gotta stop and get
some ice because you know liam needs
some ice and she had an ice maker there
linda just didn't think about it so we
walked in i said happy anniversary again
she said what's this i said mail that
check-in house is paid for eight years
into 15-year loan we paid housing wow
that's quite that's worth the lie well
played
well played
well played hey good to talk to you man
proud of you proud of you very cool
stuff
it's a
baby steps millionaires theme hour this
is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
ken coleman ramsey personalities my
co-host today this hour is a baby steps
millionaires theme hour we're talking to
real millionaires not your broke
brother-in-law
about where millionaires come from
isn't it funny how broke people have a
lot of opinions about this i've been
broke
but listen here's the thing you're not
supposed to have opinions about people
who have wealth if you're not one
unless you actually are basing that in
facts instead of your jealousy
or your socialistic tendencies
especially around here because this is
the number one and number two capitalist
pigs on the air today i like where this
is going this is so there you go hey if
you're struggling with money out there
it's all consuming i've been there i
remember being so scared i couldn't
breathe
you don't have to live with that kind of
stress
financial peace university will show you
not only how to
get out of debt and get control
and budget and save and spend wisely but
also how to become a baby steps
millionaire and how to be outrageously
generous along the way
the new course videos are out this is
the best financial peace university
we've ever had dr john delony george
campbell rachel cruz and me teaching you
nine different lessons
you plug in with a group the group
becomes your best buddies and you walk
through life with them for the next
little while and you get your act
together
and then you move on and become wealthy
and that's what we want you to do
it does work
over 10 million people have been through
this class
go to ramseysolutions.com fpu some of
you that have been through need to come
back through
because you fell off the wagon or you
flunked the first time i don't know it
can happen
um sometimes it takes people more than
once to do something i generally don't
get things right the first time do you
so maybe you need to go back through
sometimes it gets the first time and
they just go launching but
ramsay solutions.com
fpu we're talking to real millionaires
charlie is in lexington kentucky charlie
what's your net worth
net worth is just about 2.2 million good
for you give me a little breakdown on
that by category please
i've got about 1.3 million million and
401k 403 uh about 120 in taxable
investments
about 100 185 and ross 130 in cash and
uh cash accounts
got a paid for house 365 and i bought a
adjacent lot between my neighbor's house
myself for 60 grand
okay all right good way to go man all
right and so how old are you
52. good for you and how much of this
did you inherit
uh zero
okay and your range of income during
your working lifetime best year and
worst year
uh best year 300 just the north of 300
000 uh worst year starting out around
55. cool well you do what did you do or
do you do for a living
i'm actually an attorney okay all right
very good
and uh so what was your gpa in
college uh undergrad was uh about a
three
three eight uh my jd i was more around
the three point okay cool very cool
so what do you think as you look back on
this you did not inherit this money
you're talking to a 25 year old young
attorney that's out there
half your age
who's kind of got his his or her little
lip stuck out and says it can't be done
in america today
are they right
or are you right
i'm right
[Laughter]
so what advice would you have for them
well number one i hope they hadn't taken
out student loans like i did and go to
school out of state that was a mistake
but other than that i've always lived
one listen to dave ramsey that's that's
number one listen i agree with that
completely
uh really i think i think for me it's
it's you gotta live within your means
protect i think particularly when you
get into
a profession like as an attorney or
doctor and you think you're somehow you
just mentioned that you have your lips
stuck out a little bit
live within your means
don't compare yourself to others
and above all appreciate what you have
and focus on your goals and what you can
control i think that's key i love that i
got to ask you a question as a
successful lawyer does anybody care
has anybody ever really asked you and
has it done anything for you as to
whether or not you went to a law school
that they were impressed with or not how
much does the brand name of the law
school matter to success
i think it's in very limited
circumstances like anything it's what
you put into it and quite frankly again
if i had
known then what i know now i would have
saved a lot of money and maybe not have
had the student loans if i stayed in
state
because there are a lot of tremendous
attorneys who went to schools that are
statistically ranked lower than the
school that i attended right so nobody
really cares do your customers don't
care
no yeah no no my clients don't ask where
i went to law school i the judges don't
ask where i went to law school they just
look for the results there it is judge
reads a brief and goes oh he went to
harvard
no ju said no judge ever yeah
yeah i like it so what kind of law are
you practicing
i i'm in a defense defense firm i do a
lot of uh insurance defense work oh okay
wow cool good for you that's fun
so um i know the answer to this question
you're a reader more than your tv guy
right
uh absolutely yeah you can't get through
law school unless you become a reader
it's just impossible so it sticks most
docs most lawyers read like voraciously
because they have to keep up in their
world number one and you got tremendous
number of briefs and things to go
through a lot of volume of of documents
to go through i assume
a ton a ton of reading a ton of
documents you're right yeah okay well
very very cool hey man it's an honor to
speak with you congratulations we're
very proud of you proud for you very
well done jennifer is with us in st paul
minnesota jennifer what's your net worth
right around 3 million dave good for you
give me a little breakdown on that by
category please
sure i have um my home is right around
7.50
i did buy an investment property that my
son is currently living in while he goes
to school which is 250 so a million in
real estate
right around 1.8 today in my 401 case
and right around 200 000 in stock in
cash good for you how old are you
52. 52 cool and how much of this 3
million did you inherit
absolutely none zero
okay nada all right and so uh your
income range best year and worst year in
your working lifetime
well i have to tell you that first year
that um i got a job offer it was twenty
one thousand 000 so that was my first
year um i actually got the offer and i
was waitressing all throughout high
school and i said oh my gosh i am making
more than 21 000 waitressing today but i
knew that that my career as an
accountant was much more long-term so
took that 21 thousand dollar offer in
public accounting and what was your best
year and
best year um both my husband and i
combined income of about 400 000. it
worked out i like it it works yeah so
you've got a degree in accounting
okay and your gpa in school
3.5 okay cool cool
all right so what was your biggest
mistake
money-wise the stupidest thing you ever
did with money
hmm
well there's a couple things
probably the stupidest thing was when i
was in public accounting and you get out
of school and you're like oh i'm in my
profession
i upgraded
and went into
with my parents and upgraded our family
boat
so if you can imagine living in
minnesota for 12 months and nine months
of that you can't even get on the lake
or the water it is really hard to uh
write out that check for those nine
months when the boat is sitting on dry
dock and let me tell you i still
remember that coupon book today i can
remember cutting it off i can almost
remember the exact amount and thinking
every month oh my gosh i have to pay for
this and i can't even use it so that
probably was number one on my list wow
wow
what would you say to young
oh sorry you were to say number two go
ahead
number two double thing okay i just want
to know what you tell young ladies uh we
only got about 30 seconds what would you
say to young ladies who may be starting
out in their professional career about
becoming a millionaire themselves what
would you tell them
um well i would say number one um and
this is a big one for me
you can't live in a stock certificate so
don't think about buying stocks think
about owning property or real estate or
a home because in the future you can't
live in a fact certificate
that's nice interesting nice line
good stuff we're talking to real
millionaires today it's a baby steps
millionaire
theme hour
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
ken coleman ramsey personality is my
co-host today it's a baby steps
millionaires theme hour we're talking to
real millionaires in the lobby of ramsey
solutions on the debt free stage we've
got a couple of millionaires live and in
person hey guys it's uh jason and cheryl
are with us where do you guys live tampa
florida very cool thank you for joining
us here in nashville and what's your net
worth
1.2 million dollars cool give me a
little breakdown on that by category i
brought a cheat sheet okay that's good
we have two paid for houses which are a
hundred and fifteen thousand dollars
we have 250 000 in our roth and our
mutual funds
we have 72 000 and a 529
uh 45 000 in cash and then 25 000 and
just other home assets got it wow so how
long ago did you break the million
dollar mark
maybe six months ago yeah six months ago
okay so way to go how old are you two
i'm 50. and i'm 45. okay all right very
good and how much of this did you
inherit uh i inherited ten thousand
dollars from my grandmother when she
passed away and that was during our
debt-free journey so you are not
millionaires because of inheritance no
no not mathematically anyway okay
and uh your income range your best year
working household income and worst um
right now it's about 140. um and at
worst it was probably about 40 000. okay
cool and what do y'all do for a living
i do accounts receivable for a liquor
distribution company
and i work for the court systems and
then i also have a side hustle that
helps us out okay cool got four-year
degrees
i do and what uh criminal justice okay
very cool what was your gpa
like a 2.7 got it
hey hey you're my territory you're still
higher than me but no shame over there
all right no no no
i played a little too much in college i
love it so i got two quick questions one
what's the side hustle um i do social
media marketing for businesses in tampa
oh nice so you charge hourly rates or
are you on retainers um i do a monthly
rate okay good and then i'm curious how
long did it take you to become so when
you first started focusing on the
financial piece how many years to become
net worth millionaires what was that
total journey so jason got the total
money makeover book in 2004. if we would
have started back then we'd be super
rich
but we started our debt free journey in
2017 and then we did our debt free
stream in 2020. great so from 2020 to
now we've achieved that status wow
that's impressive zoom zoom yeah
yeah very cool okay so you're got people
that are uh
25 year old versions of you
sitting out there listening right now or
18 year old versions of you if it's
youtube
um
what uh what do you tell them can this
still be done because a lot of people
tell them they can't become wealthy in
america today
it can be done
why i dropped out of a college
she was homeless on the streets for a
while yeah i used to be homeless
and i was addicted to drugs for a long
time i've got 19 years clean today
congratulations so i mean i'm just proof
that you know if you commit to a program
work with a budget you can be successful
i mean i went from living in my car to
owning two houses and i'm a millionaire
now
it works if you work it
wow
what a story i'm speechless that's
amazing yeah
that's a testimony right there
that's a mic drop i mean yeah you can't
get in your american day well try me i'm
a you know 19 years sober and i used to
live in my car and now i'm a millionaire
so shut up yeah in chicago at that in
the cold winter
you weren't la homeless you were chicago
because of your program and budgeting
and like still just being frugal and
like living within our means and not
trying to keep up with the joneses and
just like rachel says being content with
what we have yeah
we've done it you know need to impress
other people really goes away once
you've lived in your car right yeah
definitely yeah and i'm just grateful
for everything that we have because it
could go away in a heartbeat yeah no no
no it's all paid for it is it ain't
going anywhere that's the whole that's
the whole reason we did this yes
yeah that's right i mean it can but you
if you if you got stupid again you could
do that right now it's not happening
yeah so as long as you just behave you
know the stuff you've done is very very
solid yeah it's put you in a very strong
position and let's point out here 1.2
million and growing because you're only
50 and 45. yeah i mean this is this is
going to just keep on expanding what a
tremendous story yeah you're a great
story you guys are amazing
yeah and so yeah that's kind of uh
anybody can do it story right there
anybody can do it because they can by
the way that's the whole purpose of this
is i kept being aggravated by this
movement out there this anti-wealth
movement that says you know that
america's so broken that you can't get
ahead today and it's impossible and
we've certainly got our problems and
there's a lot of mean and angry people
out there and a lot of people doing
nasty things to each other no question
about all that but it can still be done
it can be it can still be done and you
guys have done most of this in the last
three years yes since we became
debt-free yeah that's pretty stinking
cool right there so
very very cool
man you guys that's a great story thank
you for stopping by and sharing that
yeah we wanted to do it we're proud of
you you guys are heroes yeah today's a
special day yeah you uh you you just
inspired a whole bunch of people
somewhere out there there's a lady
that's been dry for 30 days and uh she
doesn't know if she can do it or not and
she gets to hear your millionaire story
yeah i just i can't believe how far i've
come and we've come as a couple and just
communicating and like how strong our
marriage is and then teaching the stuff
to our kids is you know
yeah yeah
absolutely yeah hey thank you for coming
god bless you absolutely amazing
so can when i meet people like that
i
feel like it's okay for me to be angry
when someone
says
all the people that are millionaires
inherited their money they're so lucky
and i meet someone like her
and him and i go
i just want to smack your little
socialist face i mean yeah it just i
can't do that it's not legal but i mean
it just in verbal infuriates me though
should because for for two reasons one
is it's so
um
dismissing and so disrespectful to
someone who's had a journey like this
correct number one number or like me i i
had to do it twice i was a millionaire
and i lost everything i had to do it
again i've been a millionaire twice yeah
i'm so dumb it took two times for it to
stick right you know and so you can tell
me it can't be done you're so lucky
lucky's butt lucky had nothing to do
with it right well the reason you're mad
and you should be mad is because this is
taking away from the individualization
the grind the struggle that this couple
went through you're talking about jason
who is a college dropout and cheryl is a
former drug addict but see that doesn't
fit the narrative because the narrative
says you need the government to take
care of you and anybody who doesn't get
all of their fortune or all of their
goodness of life from the government
well then they must be greedy or they're
cutting the rules and the fact of the
matter is they represent millions and
millions of people despite their story
they represent millions of people who
say you know what i'm gonna make my way
you can't be rich without ripping
somebody off you have to be a crook well
i didn't see any crooks there's no
crooks it's just hustle just straight up
hard work i didn't see anybody stealing
nothing yeah and the character that both
of those people have you know and you
got to be brilliant you got to have a
big gpa well today we've talked to four
three point eight three point eight
three point five four point and two
point seven i didn't see any four point
twos in there no you don't have to be
freaking albert einstein either thank
god cause that means i got a shot
and you got a shot james has a shot
telling myself there's a chance
all right that's what i'm saying there's
a chance
you know i mean seriously it's not you
you know now most of the time i don't
find 1.9 gpas you do have to have some
gray matter that's right you have to
have a little bit of intelligence you
know to be able to execute on basic
plans right and to stick with something
so most of these people are somewhere in
the high twos to mid threes sure you
know uh in terms of gpa but this idea
that geniuses or who become millionaires
no they're not this idea that famous
entertainers and athletes and whatever
our millionaire have is the only way you
become you know they're less than one
percent of america's millionaires yeah
our household names most of the people
are people like those guys right there
amazing uh you know are there an
accountant they're a lawyer they're a
teacher they're policemen's
they're they're run a flooring company i
mean these are who we've talked to today
that's correct and so these people the
problem
with you folks that are out there lying
about the wealthy
because you're mad or jealous or
whatever it is the problem with that is
it's not just that you're not you're
trying to forward some socialistic thing
the problem with your lie is you're
stealing the hope yeah from people who
legitimately have a chance to go do this
but if they believe your narrative they
don't have it they don't think they have
a chance so they don't go do it that's
correct you're hope stealers yes and you
hope steelers
you need to be smacked yeah
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
our scripture today hebrews 13 16 and do
not neglect doing good and sharing for
with such sacrifices god has pleased
fred rogers
said i hope you're proud of yourself for
the times you've said yes
when all it meant was extra work for you
and was seemingly helpful only to
someone else
yeah thank you mr rogers very good gotta
love mr rogers gotta love it ken coleman
ramsey personality is my co-host today
this is a baby steps millionaires theme
hour we're talking to real millionaires
asking them how they really did it
claire is in boise idaho hi claire what
is your net worth
uh my net worth is seven million dollars
wow impressive and give me a little
breakdown on that please by category how
much real estate retirement and so on
sure so i have 2.3 million in real
estate that's two residences
i have 3.4 in 401k ira funds
310 in stock individual stock
um 345 in cash
um
405 in deferred comp
and then i have another 300 excuse me
240
in
donor advised funds hsa and other mutual
funds wow okay
great plan you i've got a super plan
going here i love the numbers
so uh how old are you
i'm 64. cool and how much of this money
did you inherit
i inherited a hundred thousand dollars
uh but i was already a millionaire at
that point okay so you did not become a
millionaire because of inherited money
but you got a substantial inheritance
i did go okay good and um what was the
uh i mean what was your best year
working income and your worst year
working income since you
started life
so 24 000 was my worst it was my first
year out of college
and then um 435
grow adjusted gross income was last year
wow okay what do you do for a living
um recently retired but i was in uh
executive management of a financial
services company
ah
okay explains your beautiful portfolio
okay
very good all right and so your degree
uh in finance maybe
actually no it was in political science
all right and your gpa
it was around 3.4 i if as i recall
okay so you spent a lot of your life in
leadership and or in the business of
showing people that this can be done
correct i i was not necessarily on the
front line retail but um it was
you know our business
but you're building products and people
that allow people to build wealth
correct absolutely
so you knew it could be done so what do
you obviously you think that this can
still be done i assume
oh very much so and and i have to say
dave going back to my uh youth
um my dad gave us a book this predates
all your good work but my dad gave us a
book called the richest man in babylon
as we as he shoved us out the door to
the university and um even in my lean
years
i saved at least 10 percent of my
pre-tax
income for uh retirement and um that was
a huge factor
in what i have i read that book when i
was 13 my dad made us do it too
and i still sell that book we bought
it's a public domain and we print a
ramsey version of it and sell it here
it's it's well worth it it really
resonated with me um back then
yeah it's a great great parable and it
does it gets your get your attention it
was one of the first of the little
parable books like that that did a huge
volume and
very the richest man in babylon for
those of you listening that didn't
listen well so yeah pretty impressive
yeah claire i want to ask you about that
so when you began to save early on as
you look back on it what did that do for
you beyond you know obviously saving the
money
what was the principle or what's
something that you would share with
somebody younger and say here's what i
learned from that discipline of saving
well
one of my motivations was i didn't want
to be a burden to anyone in my family
in my later years and i that that dates
back to way back then and
um
it just
felt to me that it was the right thing
to be doing and not just living beyond
my means if you will there was there was
a reason for it for it and that was to
look to the future
and when you see the compounding of your
money even in the in the early days it's
it's a motivation to continue along
those lines now a lot of people we talk
to have a one or a two million dollar
net worth yours is uh 3x or 4x that um
why
why well real estate i've lived in two
very lucrative real estate markets and
so that's been a big um
benefit to me
and i worked for a very successful
financial services company where i had
stock options
and it helped propel and and had a nice
matching um always i always got the
match yeah so i had two other answers in
mind let me see if they're correct okay
uh-huh i think you started really early
i did yeah and the other thing i think
you by hanging out in the financial
services world um
that you had a lot of positive peer
pressure around you to do smart things
with money
that's absolutely true
and i've turned around and and given
that same sort of influence on the the
young people in my life yeah very good
very good um so that was my suspicion
anyway so very cool very cool
oh man you just uh you're a wealth of
information here there's a lot of a lot
of things people can draw from your
particular story claire i want to ask
you you're recently retired first of all
congratulations yeah that's amazing and
clearly you're prepared for it so i'm
curious
what is the next chapter look like for
you
because i'd love to hear that picture
now that you're very young at 64 and
retiring
well um i'm still figuring that out to
be quite honest with you i've relocated
and am finding my new community
and picking up a few hobbies of uh
re-picking up my uh love of golf
and um and just trying to find my way my
most important to me is family and being
available and and interacting and
spending time with them so that is um
still like i said still unfolding yeah
but so like like we say a financial
piece you know what you can do if you
have seven million dollars anything you
want and that's what i wanted people to
hear you don't have to have a fancy
answer you have a lot of peace around
this right now you're so stressed
you're just easing into this oh i know
what the other thing i wanted to ask you
was because i i'm trying to think of
someone sitting out out there with their
being negative um and i'm solving their
objections in a sense here uh
during your working life while you amass
a seven million dollar net worth by 64
years old uh were you like living in a
cave collecting lent and only coming out
on triple coupon thursdays or did you
enjoy your life and travel and do other
things
i i enjoyed my life um
and
well i'll have to say it wasn't until my
40s
that i actually felt comfortable enough
to buying a home in a particular
particular market i was in
um
because i didn't want to overextend
myself but um yeah i traveled i
um
i
i had cars so i know you weren't you
weren't driving a thousand dollar car
and shopping at goodwill
no i was not yeah no i was not no that's
not you know sometimes people go well i
don't want to live my whole life and
then not have it you know
and you've had a good life
a great life and in the midst of that
have just been very intentional and
diligent i'm so proud of you claire
congratulations thank you for sharing
your story powerful lady right there
dude yeah she has her act again serious
i mean this portfolio is it's like
gorgeous oh it's incredible it's
beautiful
so 4 million 2.2 3 million 1.2 and 7
million we talked to real millionaires
today not your broke brother-in-law with
a political opinion
but real
ones not your friend who's sitting at
the coffee shop whining their socialist
rhetoric
real people precisely the number of them
that
they became millionaires because of an
inheritance that we talked to today
precisely zero that's correct she also
did not hear about any government
stimulus checks or student loans being
forgiven and none of them none of them
credited a former president as having
made them wealthy didn't come up based
on their vote
yeah she didn't come up didn't come up
at all
there you go folks you can do this that
puts this hour in the books we'll be
back with you before you know it in the
meantime remember there's ultimately
only one way to financial peace and
that's to walk daily with the prince of
peace christ jesus
[Music]
hey folks ken coleman here did you know
the ramsay show is one of the most
popular podcasts in the world it's your
daily dose of advice on life and money
check out all of our shows from the
ramsay network wherever you listen to
podcasts
[Music]
you